REPUBLICANS IT SEEMS.
>> Tucker: LISA BOOTHE,
THANK YOU FOR THAT.
NEWS FROM THE TECH FRONT
TONIGHT, AMAZON HAS ANNOUNCED
AFTER MONTHS OF HYPE THAT IT IS
BUILDING TWO NEW HEADQUARTER
FACILITIES.
ONE OUTSIDE OF NEW YORK CITY AND
THE OTHER OUTSIDE OF WASHINGTON
AND VIRGINIA.
JEFF BEZOS WHO IS THE WORLD'S
RICHEST MAN WILL RECEIVE MORE
THAN $2 BILLION IN SUBSIDIES
FROM YOU, THE TAXPAYER.
NEW CONGRESSWOMAN ALEXANDRIA
OCASIO-CORTEZ HAD THIS TO SAY,
"AMAZON IS A BILLION-DOLLAR
COMPANY.
THE IDEA IT WILL RECEIVE
HUNDREDS OF MILLIONS OF DOLLARS
IN TAX RATES AT A TIME WHEN A
SUBWAY IS CRUMBLING IN OUR
COMMUNITIES NEED MORE
INVESTMENT, NOT LESS, IS
EXTREMELY CONCERNING TO
RESIDENTS HERE."
I HATE TO ADMIT IT BUT
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO-CORTEZ HAS A
VERY GOOD POINT.
PROFESSOR, THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR COMING ON.
IT'S HARD TO ARGUE WITH THE
INTERNAL LOGIC, THE RICHEST MAN
IN THE WORLD JUST GOT $2 BILLION
IN TAXPAYER SUBSIDIES.
HOW DOES THAT WORK?
>> AND AGAIN, THE WHOLE POINT IS
HE'S TRYING TO COZY UP TO
POLITICIANS SO THEY WILL GIVE
HIM AND HIS COMPANY, A 200
BILLION-DOLLAR COMPANY, THE
BIGGEST TAX BREAKS AROUND AND
PUT THEM IN A POSITION WHERE
THEY CAN SEND OFF COMPETITORS
FOR YEARS TO COME BECAUSE THEY
ARE COZY WITH THE RULE MAKERS.
>> Tucker: SO YOU ARE SAYING
THAT THEY ARE PAYING HIM TO
LOBBY THEM, AND THEN YOU SEE
ADAM SCHIFF SAYING HE IS GOING
TO INVESTIGATE A PRESIDENT FOR
DARING TO CRITICIZE JEFF BEZOS.
IT'S MAKING MY HEAD SPIN.
>> JEFF BEZOS IS MOVING INTO
TOWN BECAUSE HE WANTS TO CONTROL
THE NARRATIVE, CONTROL WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN THE HALLS OF POWER.
$13 MILLION WORTH OF LOBBYING ON
100 LOBBY IS TO DEAL WITH, AND
HE WILL PUT 20,000 MORE PEOPLE
RIGHT NEXT TO D.C. IN NORTHERN
VIRGINIA EVERY TIME THERE IS AN
ISSUE THAT AFFECTS AMAZON, THERE
IS BOOTS ON THE GROUND AND THE
OFFICE OF POLITICIANS.
EVEN IF IT MEANS CONSUMERS INTO
THEIR SMALL BUSINESSES LOSE OUT.
IT'S ALL ABOUT GETTING HIS HANDS
ON THE LEVERAGE OF POWER.
>> Tucker: I'M A PROPERTY
OWNER IN THE DISTRICT OF
COLUMBIA.
HAVING LIVED HERE FOR A LONG
TIME, I CAN TELL YOU THE LAST
THING WE NEED IS MORE MONEY IN
WASHINGTON, IT'S RICH ENOUGH.
WHY WOULDN'T AMAZON, SUBSIDIZED
BY TAXPAYERS, SPREAD THE WEALTH
TO DETROIT OR CLEVELAND OR
TOLEDO, SOMEPLACE THAT ACTUALLY
NEEDS IT.
>> IT'S BECAUSE, TUCKER, DETROIT
ISN'T ANYWHERE NEAR CONGRESS.
THIS IS PURELY OF PLAY FOR
AMAZON TO BUY POLITICAL
INFLUENCE.
THEY LOOK AROUND THE WORLD AND
THEY SEE POTENTIAL COMPETITORS.
THEY LIKE BEING ON TOP AND THEY
WANT TO KEEP IT THAT WAY ON THE
WAY TO DO THAT IS TO WRITE THE
RULES OR WRITE THE REGULATION.
THEY ARE BUYING PRIME
REAL ESTATE WHERE ALL THOSE
RULES ARE WRITTEN.
THEY DISRUPT INDUSTRIES TO A
COMPANY THAT STAYS ON TOP BY